hey guys how's it going so there's a lot
of Apple news in the past couple of days
and I have missed all of it so I've been
traveling and I've been missing out on
some serious Apple news well today I
caught up and the one headline they
caught my eye
actually headlines kisses pretty much
what everyone's talking abut a free pair
of earbuds ease the pain of the iPhone 8
style no low price Jack yeah I thought 8
may actually come with Apple's best
accessory
well iPhone 8 come bundled with free air
pods free headphones I think this is
going to be an incredible decision if
Apple does decide to do this because the
headphones that come with your phone now
yeah they're great but the air pods are
fantastic and I know I have made fun of
them I've made all of the jokes possible
but when it comes down to it yeah they
don't stay in my ears perfectly but man
they are the best pair of headphones
that I have ever agree with you just on
the ease of use supportability they sink
to everything and they just freakin work
I have yet I also have yet to lose beer
by I have actually lost a set I forgot
about that
there's no good story about how I lost
it I didn't just lose the air pods that
go into my ear I lost the entire case
I have lost both air pods in the package
entirely but I have not lost a single
airplane so I feel like that's a step in
the right direction right rumors are the
iPhone 8 is going to be a thousand
dollars there's also rumors that they're
not going to be available
there's only to be a minimum amount of
them let's take a peek at that new
evidence iPhone 8 faces worst case
shortage scenario iPhone 8 facing huge
barriers that will cost shortages the
farm is reviving how she was not to be
moved I'm e-102 liked what or the
components what are they so they're
dropping the original shipments from 100
to 110 million units down to 80 to 90
what does that mean does that mean I'm
not going to get a phone so I mean
you're not going to get a phone what
does it mean okay
Apple is still expected to announce two
of the devices the iPhone 7s the iPhone
7s Plus which may still launch in
September guys these are all rumors I
don't even know what got me really hyped
with the fact that the air pods may come
with the iPhone age a lot of people were
saying that this is not possible like
this can't actually happen because
there's such a shortage of air pods
currently maybe the reason there's a
shortage is because they plan on giving
you a nice pair of ear pods with your
iPhone eight could it be could it be
people are still struggling to get air
pods when I lost mine in Hawaii I ended
up having to eBay mine so that I could
have in the next day because I'm crazy
and I was not able to live without them
this is my stock if they decide to give
you the air pods in the iPhone age will
they make the iPhone eight USBC to
compensate for your troubles yes please
compensate me for my trouble of having a
USBC iPhone eight because truthfully
it's not a trouble to me at all only
people who probably will be are those
upgrading who do not have any other USBC
products but man I am so I'm going all
in with USBC baby it is what I want it's
what I live for I wake up in the morning
and I ask USBC with the side the eggs
and toast it doesn't even make any sense
what's up iPhone 8 edge to edge
horizontally glass back iPhone 7s air
pause what kind of title is this you've
got
what information did that's title what
I'm wondering from you guys is what do
you think they're going to do is you
think that the iPhone 8 is going to now
be USBC and to compensate for that
change are they going to give us some
air plugs for free you're still buying
your soul I know just don't ever let
anyone tell you that you're getting
those for free but I do see where people
are coming from with the speculation
because if they are giving those to us
most of the people to buy that phone are
probably also going to want to buy some
sort of headphones whether it's the air
paws or some other Wireless choice I'm
not sure
a lot of them out there I'm also super
pumped about all of the rumors of a
smart home device a theory in my house
we've already got the Google home
we've got Amazon's Alexa and we also
have let me show you this
Amazon show Amazon officially unveiled
touch screen echo show looks like
something you'd see as a dentist or like
a dentist kiosk I don't know I've done
just kiosk with what I thought of maybe
because I cracked one of my teeth and
I'm still trying to recover from that
what this guy doing talk like that
except occult hey mom hi honey how are
things you forgot to mention how hard
this whole parenting thing would be and
you are forgetting with your new penis
this is Joey
first time mom and okay
but Emily would you like okay I'm just
scrolling this video but let me tell you
what if this is what Amazon is releasing
what do you think Apple could be doing
that is better than this don't get me
wrong I freaking love Amazon but when
Apple does something and they do it
right they do it right so with all of
the technology that's out there with a
Google home and Alexa and an alley echo
show what could Apple possibly
potentially be launching what have they
already made what do they have that is
ready for our home so the echo show is
229 which is kind of a it's a fairly
steep price because you could buy it if
you laptop for that like how much is the
Microsoft Surface yeah surface laptop is
999 dollars granted you're not going to
have the sort of interactivity and a
placement that you're going to have with
the Amazon echo show but look at this
you get a whole freaking computer I just
feel like a 229 I don't know you got to
make some decisions
what Wow
I don't know I'm freaking out with all
these like potential things that are
coming out anyway I just wanted to give
you guys a quick little roundup my
thoughts are everywhere because just
sitting here with you guys and surfing
the web and looking up all of these
things that could potentially be out the
rumors are they true what's good what
are we gonna have I don't know since I
have been traveling I've been so
appreciative for you guys tweeting the
updates and all kinds of cool things I
know a lot of you guys but also like to
see me try the new Oreo firecracker
fireworks cooking I'm on the lookout for
that right now
we're going to jump cut from here we are
heading to Chicago which I've actually
just got back I'm currently in New York
right now so I went from New York to
Chicago back to New York but what I
didn't tell you at the beginning of my
Chicago vlog is why I was there I went
to Chicago to be on The Steve Harvey
Show and I had the best time ever it was
so much fun that episode will be airing
later this month or maybe next month I'm
not gonna pretend sure but when I find
out I will let you guys know on Twitter
or Instagram or wherever else here we go
let's go to Chicago
[Music]
[Applause]
hey Chicago flirty hair
[Music]
okay I don't wanna fall for you
I'm falling fine
[Music]
we're going up the Willis Tower used to
be known as the Sears Tower and I kept
calling the Sears Tower and everyone
kept correcting me
so Willis we're here you're on your way
to have a daughter was molested we're
here old man we are about to get a
picture the shot in the guy Bob oh
you're making me so nervous
just slide in happy here you go wow this
is pretty terrifying one just got the
cooler shot ever check this out
tell me I didn't do it wouldn't do it
I'm a big chicken early can it's okay
it's okay you made it up here that one's
to go out yes thank you
man you must offer the lights on at the
Russian everyone's brokenhearted I'm
beautiful
[Music]
and when in Chicago you go to Portillo
disordered and now waiting for orders
you guys here 223 backs up we got
everything
I mean if you're going to do Portillo
you got a duper - thank you
these bags are really heavy
I know I did something really bad I got
a salad at Portillo's please don't yell
at me please don't yell at me look
really good oh my god
[Music]
that right there I'm concerned with all
of our safety so that's the big meat and
let me tell you what it is appropriately
named
[Music]
good morning oh my goodness if I even
tried to explain to you I guess it's not
that difficult to explain
yesterday I cracked to juice here in
Chicago I'm in Chicago what do i do I
don't have a dentist here so I tweeted
asking for Dennis and the reason that
I'm in Chicago is alone on the Steve
Harvey Show today right now it's 7:28
a.m. I have to be in the car by 7:30 to
want a Steve Harvey's recommended dennis
by 8:00 o'clock then to the studio by
10:00 a.m. for rehearsal and then we
shoot the show so that's what's
happening today I'm also sleeping in all
of my clothes and I also have my Apple
watch on and I'm also ready to go I
staged the sleeping shot no kidding
good morning Chicago sup just hope
nothing serious is wrong because they've
only got like an hour and a half to do
whatever it is they need to do so
whatever happens today hopefully it'll
last me until whenever I get back we're
done at the dentist everything is
awesome I have a temporary fix now we're
about the head ends to your hopes tea
party and I've got a lot of stuff
and Damiano is filming also have my
backpack somehow we got a vlog walk but
this is the life she'll black you try it
on look up and then you can say you
don't have to put this in there that you
can we're behind the scenes now we're
here just waiting
look I spotted hey how are you I am
fantastic yeah are you excited for this
episode of whatever we're doing that we
can't talk about yeah you know I'm very
very excited
I sound excited - hello why are you yeah
I am disciplines
well they already know where I'm going
to fit you I already gave them you think
you won't say his name Steve Harvey oh
oh oh my mom is so crazy I run my mom hi
how are you I'm great
I'm so excited okay that's enough buddy
you all right you be nice to hurt not be
nice how I'm nicer I'm acknowledging her
sister he doesn't all the time people on
Instagram okay like I just read you sure
you want to talk about it start a
channel how about that I think she
should I'll come on as a guest and I've
got some words to say as well I'm gonna
work on them when we got back here lobby
I'm walking yeah she said I'm not
supposed to be on the show what I said
that she checked with you yeah
make me but I talk to him like that yeah
we're assuming Bart's getting in trouble
[Music]
all right that's it we're done filming
this was such a long day but everything
was shot super fun I'll let you guys
know when the episode actually airs and
I'll be posting some behind the scenes
stuff from the actual show that I
couldn't show in this vlog sometime
later so thank you for that I gotta go I
gotta get on the plane and I have to
head back to New York and I don't think
my flight lands until like 1:00 a.m. and
then have to be up super early tomorrow
morning for more press stuff so come
with me friends let's go let's go please
I don't know I can't believe we have to
run the airport right now it's like a
ninth it was like bye bye thanks Steve
Harvey so fun [__] roll
oh I gotta bring my sandwich perhaps I
got the my god oh these are this
Blackwatch about coral the coral wants
not to I have crossed it we could go out
together dressed like yellow on the
coral boys work or brine on the dropping
2022 so before Voyager 3 whirl keep
sailing
oh you'll coral I'm all the colors fine
well then you have all the colors I have
a problem
come on kalca you guys have to see what
John is doing right now hold on loner to
them well let's be still
let me show he was holding the camera on
top of the people who was making do plug
boards pregnant
Roma Sarah made it it's like 1:00 a.m.
but a good news damiana pizza made it
over here here survived this is made it
1231 and now we've got a drive back to
the city over here and I okay no oh gosh
we got what a day a fun pressed and
first thing done most importantly you've
got your pizza home yesterday yes yeah
and I had some for breakfast
[Music]
I filled almost its entire lottery on my
lap and thankfully it's just like sunk
into my skin and into my body and into
my pants and you can't even tell
thankfully I didn't get any on the car
it was just all over myself hey guess
what I did build this on my lap no you
can't tell look I mean what about the
burn it wasn't hot thankfully all right
we're going into South code live hosted
by Frankie grande and separator right
now we're here
Stockholm ad let's go we are in green
room now just waiting to go on we're
doing an unboxing today and I'm super
excited about it it's going to be out in
I think like a week or so we'll see TBD
I'll tweet about it so you'll see it on
my Twitter look at all these boxes of
item we just finished up a segment it
was super fun I will put a link in
description where you guys can check out
Frankie's show and we're striking for
SIA we just did something I don't want
to say what we did yet because it's not
out yet so it will be out very very soon
so you got some playlists I took it back
and playlist I want some merch line you
can check it all out I'm a website
shopper if I Frankie calm I'll put it in
the description yes well you oh you knew
you got so what's not going on all my
stuff is going when is it posted if I
will tomorrow if you both smiled and I'm
doing a show in London on the 27th at
which you can pre-order tickets to you
also that link down here you know I was
gonna put all of Frankie's link so you
know doesn't know description is
important for it it's all right bro oh
my gosh I haven't seen you since I look
like a stream you favor one thing like a
long time ago
I mean well you're here on Falco live
which is amazing you know the show is so
much fun I love it they're French oh
it's super cute and then something else
we're coming on hopefully you guys will
stay tuned for that well thanks for
being my blog I love let's get the light
right over here okay much better thank
you
that brings this vlog to a close if you
guys enjoyed it and I will see you
in tomorrow's video whatever that
happens to be unless I don't post the
video tomorrow and you could just maybe
rewatchable one I'll see you later bye
[Music]
prove it